hello you're watching games but daily
where we cover six news stories in 30
minutes or less or your mattresses free
I'm Callie and I'm joined by Michael hi
um Oh mattress yeah we got a new one
every day a new deal I bought a CD I
bought a super firm mattress like I
usually like hard beds but I got a
quote-unquote super firm mattress from
Ikea when I moved out here in San
Francisco
turns out it was really hard like it was
like hella hard and then but I got used
to it
right so I would a new mattress would be
dope so let's try and go over 30 minutes
so maybe I can get that get that sweet
mattress okay but you know we'll see how
this all shakes out so today we're
talking about a lot of things we got
ubisoft at e3 we got cool japanese games
and fortnight news and more those are
only three things but you know we
disagree Syracuse what David there's a
lot to go around it's it's so April is a
little tricky because it tends to be a
slower news cycle but bear with us
because we still find some dope stuff
yeah talk about we got to believe it or
not we got y'all all right so first off
Ubisoft has revealed the date and time
for its e3 showcase so it's set at the
Orpheum Theatre in Los Angeles on
Saturday June 11th at 1 p.m. Pacific
time
and it'll have a live pre-show and
post-show and all that good stuff yeah
we it's not a surprise to have will be
soft at e3 of course because they've had
their press conferences pretty much
every years for the past couple years
yeah
but the fact that they announced their
time and date is exciting so now we can
finally say with confidence that we will
get a splinter cell no we're not gonna
say that with on the poor people oh man
but yeah now that they have a time date
and we know where they're gonna be we
can start to think about what they're
gonna be showing you guys an exciting
time and they they did are not confirmed
but we are expecting to see division 2
because they announced it with few
details and then promised more at e3 so
it's pretty likely but of course there's
a lot of other things that we are hoping
to see I think one of those would be
Beyond Good and Evil 2 which is
announced
last year's e3 and obviously won't be
out by the time this e3 is coming around
so maybe they would show off more yeah
Beyond Good and Evil 2 is one of the
more exciting and surprising things that
would be soft is working on and like you
said we would expect to see more maybe
some gameplay no this is a kind of a
it's been a mystery I know tomorrow saw
it last year behind closed doors but you
know I still don't have a really good
grasp of what it is because but Beyond
Good and Evil one was like your third
person an adventure from the early 2000s
that's incredibly well done but of
course the landscape is different
nowadays so who knows what Beyond Good
and Evil 2 will actually play out to be
it supposed to be like a multiplayer
persistent world sort of thing if I'm
not mistaken but whatever that means or
what it whatever it ends up being for
rills it's exciting yeah other games
that there that were revealed last year
that won't be out by this year's e3
include Skull and Bones the pirate game
star link battle for Atlas that like I
remember being like what is happening
and then the crew - which kept getting
delayed that's a little different but
that's a June 29th release yes so that's
a little that's quickly after e3 yeah I
know some things about the crew to you
but I can't talk about thanks for that
Michael
yeah uh what else do you think I mean
Ubisoft obviously we've had that you
know Splinter Cell tease recently with
Sam Fisher being in Ghost Recon
wildlands some time I would imagine that
one of the things would probably be it's
time Splinter Cell or I would hope I
guess um oh yeah I would I think I would
bet money on that actually I would I was
that money to blacklist came out in 2013
so that's five years in a minute yeah
that was the last core splinter cell
game that we got and you know you're not
gonna bring Michael Ironside into into
the booth just for one Ghost Recon DLC I
mean that's it's like okay we have him
in here to do something else so we'll
get Ghost Recon wildlands DLC with him
in it
to get some hype behind hey dude just
come and do this one line real fast yeah
well when you have
yeah because he's I swear brah he's
doing a new splinter so I hope gotta be
and then obviously I mean they have
watchdogs I don't know what other cities
could they do watch dachshund oh no I
was I think obviously London is the most
surveilled city in the world so I was
thinking that you know they did Chicago
they did San Francisco or they well they
did the Bay Area but so much has changed
that maybe if they do something still
within the Bay Area like they can do
some cool things like cryptocurrency and
dude we have these weird scooters that
just showed up like two weeks ago
and we're not here on CBS yeah no no
just a around the city these apparently
there's a scooter startup that just is
like putting these rentable scooters on
the street and they're in everybody's
way and they're the worst and if you're
doing a watchdogs three presumably you
could hack the scooters that Bataille it
I think Nick margarita tried to hack one
of the scooters because he was so
determined me he wanted to see how it
worked I don't know and then lastly I
think I mean we just had an assassin's
Creed game I don't know if maybe DLC
maybe DLC but maybe something more from
from the Rabbids ooh
Mario more Mario Rabbids or just general
Rabbids you think rabbits have earned
their earn their own game a separate
from Raymond and Mario Lisson I thought
I was a big rabid skeptic I wasn't I
think they're hideous
I don't alarm honey I hate them
generally but Mario Plus rabbits is it
was saved by a game yeah I was saved by
being a good game yeah so we gave the
rabbits a pass they're fine I guess
sure yeah yeah that's that's ubisoft's
at e3 e3 is so soon we have a counter up
in our office it's like 52 days or
whatever I'm not sure and then every
like minute it flashes this picture of
Reggie fils-aime a but just says like
are you Rick what does it say I don't I
don't know what it says it case flashes
by so fast I thought I was having a
stroke I was like what
we're handling the e3 the impending III
madness super well here at GameSpot um
it's not sure totally different thing
this has nothing to do with III
whatsoever and also nothing to do with
anything I'm particularly well versed in
but Michael you are a tech savvy dude I
am taking this one over mm-hmm AMD is
firing back at Nvidia for their GPP
their g-force Partnership Program which
is got got board partners on unlock
essentially so I'm PC gamer yes this is
coming from PC gamer so AMD is met
they mad animal spots they they've said
some things in blog posts and they have
also said that they are putting out new
lines of Radeon cards now this doesn't
mean that there's going to be new RX
Vega
video cards doesn't mean that there's
going to be the next generation coming
out soon but they are partnering with
other brands to get like an extra push
for their existing cards I believe now
if they come out and surprises say a we
got rx Vega 2 coming out soon that would
be dope but I don't expect that but in
response they are trying to push for
more board more versions of their
existing cards so if you don't know the
GeForce partner program gives board
partners extra marketing support and
perks if the if the developers align
themselves with Nvidia so video is
basically saying is that hey you know
devote your loyalty to us and in in turn
we will give you marketing tools you
plead your plead pledge your fealty
I put our kingdom I pledge allegiance to
Nvidia and then you get a bunch of
marketing money and tools and sure and
obviously Amy's not gonna be happy about
that
what aim he said well specifically that
they're not happy about this but they
commented in a blog post and they said
this specifically our proud Pat I get
this first line I can't really take too
serious but anyway our proud pastime of
PC gaming has been built on the idea of
freedom I'm gonna stop you right there
Michael there's freedom dog come on ow
proud pastime of PC gaming has been
built on the idea of freedom actually
sounds like the beginning of a super
rousing speech with like a music behind
it and like a cheesy movie it's not
sounds like the opening lights are ready
player to you sorry so they continued
freedom to choose how to play the game
what to do and when to do it and
specifically what to play it on PC
gaming has long as it has a long proud
tradition of choice oh my god what piece
of gaming isn't a country what is this
dude they're saying this this [ __ ] with
their hands over their hearts whether
you build or upgrade your own pcs or
pre-order pre-built rigs after you've
customized every detail online you know
that we're that that what what that what
you're paying for is your own making
based on your freedom to choose the
company the components that you want
yeah the components that you want
freedom of choice is a staple of PC
gaming I feel like shoes is like I feel
like they said like three circles of the
same thing over again but it's like
they're talking about reproductive
rights but with PC gaming and I think
it's because I really do some video
cards yeah I had a lot of fun I built my
PC and I'm saving up for new parts cuz
it totally broke Michael can't help you
and I get it I get what they're going
for but it's just a lot it's a lot but
if you think about it I mean AMD has
been trailing Nvidia for a very long
time in terms in the graphics card
business if you look at the Steam
Hardware surveys like over 80% of like
it's not indicative of everyone but in
the steam hardware surveys over 80% of
people are using Nvidia video cards
so as AMD I mean they're not like
they're doing fine since they're putting
out new new generations of cards and
they absolutely still exist but as a
competitor of course you want to build
on something you know RX Vega a series
of cards were actually pretty dope with
some slight things that I didn't like
too much about them like power draw
they're very hungry for power but those
cards yeah they ain't cards but it
presented a viable alternative to
Nvidia's high-end graphics cards so I
mean it's not like
MD is struggling to create worthy
products
it's just that Nvidia feels like it
feels like they're using their leverage
and uncompetitive ways which is kind of
what the initial thought was with the
geforce partner program so you know the
more competition the better products
that we get I think and then like
something like GPP kind of like
undercuts that but yeah so you're saying
AMD has a point
they definitely buy it for for anybody
who's not following the the graphics
card drama the scene yeah and then
anything else that you want to mention
from this we got yeah it's it's weird
because Asus and gigabyte are both
manufacturers uh they're both board
partners of AMD and NVIDIA so I think
that Asus is creating their own they
have like the the rog or the wrong Strix
like branding but I think they're
starting a new branding called a res for
AMD specifically to kind of like make
the divide between their nvidia line and
AMD line now i'm not for not entirely
sure what that'll mean or what that will
look like or how that's gonna play out
but just knowing that there is drama in
the video card world is something
because AMD is not happy with the
geforce partner program and what Nvidia
is doing to kind of leverage their way
to getting like almost a monopoly on the
video card business I don't know it's a
crazy times for PC games and you
probably can't even find a video card
for a regular price right now because
cryptocurrency thanks Bitcoin
cryptocurrency mining is making a
killing you know yeah well there you
have it that's your TMZ report I'm not a
breath anyway
totally hard right we got some fun news
for all of you monster hunters out there
Monster Hunter world's latest update
launches today and it adds a new elder
dragon armor sets and a new quest type
oh yeah it's a couple things so the new
elder dragon is the gold plated cold
tore off no clue how to pronounce that
yeah let's roll with that I think I did
the best that I could with what I got
and then there's a new type of hunting
quest called sieges or they are called
sieges and their limited time hunts that
all players in the gathering hub can
participate in its that 16 hunters in
total going on these sieges and you're
split into groups of 4 that can all work
together yeah
so tonight's siege is against a cold
cold to Roth shelter a hair metal band
but uh yeah the primary goal is to repel
the elder dragon who's all plated out in
gold if you didn't know that said to
have a nice dragons are wants to do yeah
it's set in a new area called caverns of
El Dorado gold that you know ok yeah
yeah it's very very on the nose the cold
turrets golden golden mantle is made of
a made of weapon relics that can be
looted and Capcom on PlayStation Blog
said we don't have much information on
when and where cult auth has amassed all
these relics so the nature and the
quality of these weapons are entirely up
to fate I think they should read type
and staff I like that because they like
set it as if they were in the world but
really it was just like random drops
yeah so yeah I think that's cute
materials collected from the elder
dragon can be used to craft new alpha
and beta armor sets as well as the new
palico gear that comes in this update
palek oh so cute I know I love the Pala
Coast there's also two new layered armor
sets that will be introduced in the
update so layered armor sets can be
equipped on top of other armor sets to
change their appearance and that's
what's happening you thinking about pala
cos palette goes because of the next
story Oh perfect transition alright and
then lastly the culture Aussies will
only be available for a limited time
like the as is expected it's unclear how
long it'll be available for but Capcom
said it'll return at some point in the
future as with the other events like the
the wiggler head or whatever so this
seems dope the only thing I'm considered
about is how much of a pain in the ass
it is to get groups together in Monster
Hunter world
in asking supporters in life was you
know some of us only have like two
friends yeah but so to do this event
sorry about your microphone to do this
event I think that you you get into one
of the hub worlds and then it'll match
you from there
and they need to break off two teams of
four so I don't think it would be as
hard it is to get the right group of
friends we'll see how that matchmaking
will play out maybe it'll be a total
mess maybe it'll be streamlined
we know it's but I know that John Luke
and Ben Gingka are going to try to do
something with the community because
they always have played Monster Hunter
on stream with the community on Fridays
I've got that Monster Hunter Friday
stream 11:30 every Friday yeah so the PT
so they may or may not try and do this
with the community who knows but like
they're thinking they're looking into it
definitely gonna check it out on Friday
stream I think yeah but that's exciting
but palek o's are probably the best part
of monster hunter world undoubtedly
speaking of palate goes in cat's neck Oh
lots may VR is coming at ps4 in Japan
and it launches May 31st Japan so okay
this comes from Anime News Network and I
threw the story in because neck lots may
is the finest mobile game ever made so
the official Japanese PlayStation
website revealed Nikhil atsume VR for
ps4 so psvr and it'll be available on
the PlayStation Store in Japan starting
May 31st and the PSV are like feature
features let you play with toys with the
cats so I can't we have screenshots
actually or anime news network a
screenshot so let's take a look at this
imagine these screenshots imagine them
in VR them imagine them in your face so
we got we got this cat look at these
cats it's a little hard to see because
but oh my god can i zoom in any more
would it be gentle it's good in this
good um oh these are so good look at
them you can see them inside your house
see here's the the photography mode if i
buy them toys you can buy them toys take
photos just like you can in the regular
game obviously
it was on so ok we'll talk about right
oh my gosh this is the this is the most
important one is like you could play a
toy with the play toys with play with
cat with toys sure I'm English is hard
but this is this is everything I live
for I'm just really happy that this
exists so a word about neko atsume
though just the mobile game soneca
Watson I first launched in October 2014
and for a while you could only get it in
Japanese and so I played in Japanese for
a long time and it was funny just like
trying to figure out what each thing cuz
they were like weird kanji that I'd
never seen before works my kanji is
really bad and I'm a baby
and but basically you put toys down and
you put food in your yard and then cats
come and they hang out in your yard and
it's all stray cats just howling into
your yard
just you attract stray cats to your yard
and then you collect them and so the the
english subtitle is NECA wat to make
kitty collector is basically what but
necklace cat is like and it's been
downloaded more than 19 million times
worldwide since it debuted in October
2014 damn right um and I think I still I
still have it on my phone like I had it
on my phone since I got it in 2015 which
is when I think it really blew up in the
States at least so I'm really hoping
this comes to because we have a psvr in
our house I don't have one but my
roommate has one and I will steal it to
play it with cats neko atsume is cute as
[ __ ] if y'all don't know like I'm gonna
keep it real with y'all like this game
is cute it's cute as [ __ ] man like
realtalk my my girlfriend that's like
one of her favorite games if you can
call it that but it's a life is game
what's not a game sure alright but you
just there's there's this jingle that
plays in the original mobile game and it
just got stuck in my head and all I can
think about is tubs which is one of the
cats one of the cats and Ames is they
all have names - you have different
names I don't know their english names
really because i do i don't think i ever
changed the language of mine
my favorite was tubs because he's like
he's a fat cat and then anytime he comes
into your yard you like a lot obviously
they only come with their food but every
time he's in your yard he's laying on
his back with
he has sleepy eyes pull up a picture has
like crumbs on his mouth and then he's
just like and he's like it was a really
cute fat cat tubs oh yeah he's guys
handles
here's tubs oh no I didn't mean to open
top to bottom a wiki top says his own
wiki page there he says oh good times he
has his paw on his belly I so some of
the cats are really great like there's
this one that shoves it so so so
basically the cool thing about Nick a
lot say well your first good talk about
Nicholas today for a little bit you can
put like the depending on what you put
down in your house or your yard that
changes what kinds of cats will show up
and what they'll do and what they'll do
when they get there so like in this it's
just like so tubs like it depends on if
like he'll eat all your food so you're
like you don't want him to eat your
expensive food you want him to eat the
cheap food and some will like stick
themselves in a box some will actually
play with the toys that you put out and
some of them will know do they do like
yeah yeah if you like dumb [ __ ] - he's
about to drop the hottest single like
he's just like but he's a chef yeah
story of the day is that Nick autumn a
is coming to psvr
in Japan now this is our this is our cry
for help to get it to North America so
please because I will buy it and I will
play it speaking of James James
I can't speaking of games that all here
coming to Japan so far oh yeah we got a
new Castlevania mobile game announced
it's called castlevania grimoire of
Shadows and it was announced for ios in
japan no one else before other regions
so far the beta is also only announced
for Japan at this time yes so
Castlevania grimoire of shadows grimoire
of Shadows yeah features characters
throughout the Castlevania history like
Alec are and Simon Belmont some of our
floats but this website says Quinn were
grimoire souls so our souls
oh why does it say grimoire of souls
sorry we uh sorry about that
we messed that one up but it's grimoire
of souls as you can see from the
official webpage here now just so y'all
know this is a multiplayer game or it's
multiplayer emphasis we're not sure if
there's any single player quite yet but
it's a multiplayer game how about four
player co-op
4v4 versus and a boss rush mode where
you can co-op but I'm wondering you know
what if you dropped like a hundred
Dracula's onto a castle
battle royale for souls or something
that's not what this game is but one can
dream you can sign up for the closed
beta as this they usually literally use
the Greek beta symbol just to say
because it says closed beta test and you
can sign up here it has information on
the story the system's the screenshots
on this website look at some of the
screenshots yeah it's uh we can scroll
through these so yeah it has characters
throughout the series I don't know if
you oh yeah yeah touched on that while I
was reading the Japanese though this
this game has some has some backstory
there's a lot going on some ridiculous
backstory so let me tell you a little
bit about the backstory here it's set in
the future after Dracula has been
defeated with two new lead characters
which you can see here I believe this is
them yeah so you have a Kenya re kado
who works in an anti anti Dracula
Department of the government Kenya RT
cuddle Lucy like she doesn't get a last
name or feed which did she come overseas
from America to help with the anti
Dracula program
I mean she's blonde so probably also
she's a magician and she's a magician so
we got the we got the anti Dracula
defense for its defense force leader in
Kenya and we have Lucy who is a magician
and what their powers combined you can
rid the world of all the remnants of
Dracula which is what Castlevania is
tends to be about but yeah that's that's
what's up
it's Castlevania on iOS it's not gonna
be no symphony of the night or circle of
the moon or aria of sorrow or dawn of
sorrow it's not gonna be none of those
dope games but
it's a mobile game and you know we can
cry all we want about not getting a true
2d well this game is gonna be a 2d
side-scrolling Castlevania but we can
cry all we want about not having it on
like switch or ps4 but if you think
about it the mobile market is huge so
this makes sense for Konami to put this
out on mobile capitalize on that sweet
Castlevania IP mm-hmm yeah and if you're
still hungry for Castlevania there is an
animation not an anime there's an
animated series on Netflix he's learning
so much from man I can't I can't even
think back to like just this time last
year looking back at myself what I
didn't know I had no [ __ ] I know nothing
before anime I mean I've been in and out
of anime ever so often throughout my
time on earth yeah but it never has a
there's never been a better time to be a
weed
I'll tell you how much yeah but yeah
this is something that I wanted to make
very clear on this show
Castlevania Netflix series is not an
anime it's just anime style Danna
mayshen very strong about this I talked
about I talked about this with Peter
when it came out and we were both like
frothing at the mouth I can get behind
that though however that series was on
our best adaptations list last year and
best Netflix exclusives it is a cool
series there were only four episodes I
enjoyed watching it the animation is
nice the voice acting school like it's a
cool show and the second season is
coming this summer so if you're into
Castle many others that would it be fair
to ask you right now I don't wanna blow
up your spot but would it be fair to ask
you what makes the distinction between
an anime and like an animated series so
I think I kind of know but just for if
y'all out there like wondering a why
right I like to I mean it's fun to joke
about it's fun to like just like [ __ ] on
looking anime esque stuff however I
think it's similar the Castlevania
series is similar to like Avatar The
Last Airbender in which the animation is
partially done by Japanese Studios a lot
of people say like oh to be anime it has
to be made in Japan I don't know
Sara Lee agree with that this is
distinctly like a westernized take on
the anime style it's just like it's a
it's clearly like a western directed
show with inspirations from anime and it
just it's it's hard to explain
it's very nitpicky it's kind of like how
I'm mostly kidding like I don't really
care if you call it an anime but so is
it fair to say it's like how SpongeBob's
not anime
spongebob is 100% not an anime but like
Avatar The Last Airbender some of the
animation was done by Japanese animator
Japanese animation studios but I think a
lot of it has to do with the artistic
direction like from the like the
creative direction for me at least I
think would it be fair to say that you
will know it when you see it yeah I
think it's easy to tell I mean like I
can't make an anime like I don't think I
have the sensibilities to make an anime
regardless I can't draw either but
anyway we're running out of time we got
to get to work this one's quick so
really quick for tonight's
guided-missile has been removed for good
this time
get your ass out of here the guided
missile has been polarizing since it was
introduced and it's now put into the
ball for good could be taken out again
in the future Bruno's mm-hmm do we want
to read epic statement we need to it was
previously removed temporarily due to a
glitch but you know a lot of bad
feedback on the guided-missile people or
not about that life
epic also talked about the upcoming
three point five point two update which
has bug fixes weapon balance tweaks
stuff like that it fixes a bug where you
would shoot your own structure
accidentally when peeking out
okay so collision detection improvement
and finally fortnight's week eight
challenges are also live now and we have
we round those up on game comm if you
want like a kind of an outline of what
those are yeah
so you can break down all your fortnight
news but guided missiles get you ass out
here oh that was actually one of the one
of the clips we cut for our video review
cuz I was with Nick when we were doing
that and we're like oh yeah put the
guided-missile in there that that's just
tight almost not in there anymore and
it's actually kind of cheap it's really
not fun to be killed by Qaeda missiles
so I respect that anyway we did it under
30 minutes we've we've mastered this my
is twitching randomly Thank You Emily
Conti Tony Wilson Matt Padgett Eric Tay
Chris Pereira you're sick but we still
love you
he's sick he's got his purse thank you
for sticking around when we talked about
Nicole sue thank you so much for
sticking around for that because we have
so much fun doing this and we hope that
you have fun chillin with us hmm
stick around because John Luke psyche
and Ben genka are going to be streaming
the hottest original Xbox games that
came to backwards-compatibility
yesterday so it's gonna be a trip down
memory lane memory lane for all you a G
Xbox owners and you can chill with them
because they're a lot of fun - mm-hmm
sorry with that see you tomorrow peace
bye-bye oops my bad
bye
you